let's go - okay I'm gonna owe is on the
phone I think I remember the
pronunciation here ilysm ed Guha Okafor
is joining us from the five one three
did I get that right wrong it's only
somebody why oh Lisa medulla okay
alright next time I'm gonna do it
good what's going on oh yeah regarding
Michigan and Nevada and I mean I have to
be honest like that kind of scares the
crap out of me that you know the
president's you know thinking about you
know extorting States I mean I think one
of the judges who were in the
impeachment trials he literally had an
example of the bridge and you know this
is just like another example of club you
know dis extorting States to do what he
wants and I mean we're in the middle of
a global pandemic and I think I just
wonder how you know not just like the
tweets itself but like how well like is
you know I guess animosity towards
absentee ballot voting like will it you
know be a thing like well he thought
like limiting people from voting yes so
just just so people know that this what
Trump tweeted was Michigan sends
absentee ballots to seven point seven
million people ahead of primaries in
general election this was done illegally
and without authorization by a rogue
Secretary of State I will ask to hold up
funding to Michigan if they want to go
down this voter fraud path this is this
is a totalitarian nightmare potentially
that's shaping up here because remember
Trump always talks about federalism the
power of the states all of this stuff
states are totally within their light
right to decide how they want to run
their elections and in fact the
presidential election is not a national
election it's 50 state elections and if
States want to do vote-by-mail they can
do it they're allowed to do that so when
Trump says I don't like it and I might
not give the money this is exactly the
type of constitutional crisis that
unless we really are sure that we can
trust
our systems of checks and balances which
we can't be sure of right now Trump
could actually get away with and it
could be absolutely destructive it's
horrifying what he's doing what he's
saying anyway no no I mean listen I
don't want it I'm not you all know I'm
not alarmist but so so like for example
Trump if he loses in November will
probably say it was rigged but he is
going to leave like he's not gonna
physically resist you know it so I want
to be reasonable with people the stuff
Trump is now threatening on the
vote-by-mail is is genuinely scary and
then I do have another question I don't
know even about this but there was news
about a cyber criminal group that
allegedly like hacked Trump's law firm
in New York and they said that they had
bad things honestly I think that it was
like a load of BS but apparently
somebody like got a hold of somebody
like paid the ransom hackers the money
to like get a hold of the data but I
mean I don't know who so I was wondering
if you know you could share some
thoughts on that story I actually I
don't know anything about that I haven't
even heard of that okay yeah that's okay
I'll look into it all right thank you I
really appreciate the call great to hear
from you mm-hmm all right take care well
I'm sure hear from ou again next time
I'll get his name right